cómo entender la obesidad
las palabras sobrepeso y obesidad
significan que el peso corporal de una
persona es más alto que lo que se
considera saludable para su estatura en
general las personas pueden tener
sobrepeso u obesidad debido a un
desequilibrio de energía la energía
entrante proviene de las calorías en los
alimentos que usted consume la energía
saliente es la cantidad de calorías que
su cuerpo quema durante la actividad
física con el tiempo si la energía
entrante es menor que la energía
saliente usted bajará de peso
si la energía entrante es más o menos
igual que la energía saliente su peso se
mantendrá
si la energía entrante es mayor que la
energía saliente usted subirá de peso
entre los factores que influyen al
desarrollo de la obesidad se incluye un
estilo de vida en activo falta de acceso
a lugares para hacer ejercicio
falta de acceso a alimentos saludables
una dieta rica en alimentos altos en
calorías grasos y azucarados comidas con
porciones de gran tamaño
tener antecedentes familiares de
sobrepeso u obesidad
enfermedades como el hipotiroidismo y el
síndrome del ovario poliquístico
los efectos secundarios de algunos
medicamentos
falta de sueño
y emociones que pueden hacer que desee
comer más
y anuncios de alimentos y bebidas de
alto contenido calórico y poco
saludables
y la obesidad aumenta su riesgo de
desarrollar problemas de salud tales
como diabetes tipo 2
presión arterial alta
y colesterol alto
y enfermedades cardíacas
accidente cerebrovascular
y ciertos tipos de cáncer
si tiene preguntas sobre la obesidad
hablé con su proveedor de atención
médica